après 45 minutes de transport armen
arrive enfin dans son lieu préféré son
poudlard à lui une boutique versailles
est spécialisée dans les produits
dérivés harry potter après avoir regardé
les huit films en trois jours se
passionna à craquer s'est décidé à faire
chauffer une nouvelle fois la carte
bleue en fait je pense que l'univers et
nous a tellement inspiré en ce sens se
sent tellement bien en fait quand on
quand on se plonge dedans quand on a
envie d'avoir
voilà des petits trucs qui qui nous
permettent d'y rester en fait c'est en
s'entourant petit à petit de tous ces
trucs là on se dit en fait moi aussi je
veux en faire partie
pour répondre à la demande toujours plus
croissante la boutique ouverte en 2017
propose aujourd'hui près de 2500
références dont de nombreux objets
dérivés des animaux fantastiques la
nouvelle saga issus de l'univers harry
potter et qui redynamise la franchise
depuis deux ans avec le phénomène des
animaux fantastiques
il ya un une nouvelle une nouvelle vague
de fans
harry potter on à la nouvelle génération
en fait qui connaît pas forcément harry
potter et qui a peut-être lui un harry
potter et qui a regardé animaux
fantastiques
il ya une nouvelle vague en fait qu'un
train arrivait la magie d'harry potter
et des animaux fantastiques a également
touché ce magasin culturel des
clayes-sous-bois peluche baguette dvd
surtout une quarantaine de livres sont
mises en avant dans les allées
actuellement on peut retrouver les
animaux fantastiques sous forme de livre
pour les passionnés les règles du kitsch
pour les plus jeunes un pop up de
poudlard
ainsi poudlard n'aura plus de secrets
pour nos petits lecteurs chaque semaine
plus d'une centaine de livres sur le
célèbre sorcier sont vendus ici dans
cette enseigne
des chiffres qui devraient augmenter l
approche de noël je suis muet bourg pour
les tomes 4 5 chiche
cet envoi poche pour mater fille qui
veut ça pour noël parce qu'elle vient de
tomber dedans dans la lecture ces livres
là et donc elle adore ça et comme en
plus à l'année plus de vingt ans après
la sortie du premier livre harry potter
ne semble pas avoir pris une ride auprès
des fans et reste l'une des franchises
les plus puissantes au monde
l'univers aurait engrangé à ce jour près
de 26 milliards de dollars de recettes
depuis son lancement